that's suspicious maybe they're backing
the upside down who's this guy
that's lucas that's lucas it must be
what lucas didn't die or anything he
looks so much older
so everyone looks kind of the same yeah
he looks so much older that's right man
i mean that's lucas but i'm pretty sure
oh my god he looks so different to me
what is happening reject nation looks
like we got another
little tiny ass trailer for the stranger
things for today
a little sneak peek uploaded onto their
channel directly let's see what's in
store and then
we'll probably go frame by frame and
make whatever completely accurate
predictions
we can make let's do this
[Music]
cool how far we've come
he's almost here
she's got hair there's stuff oh
we have a flight over time to go frame
by frame
ah get caught up this won't be coming
out till 2022 from my understanding
nope all right so obviously the first
half of this trailer is just recapping
seasons one through three watching it
while you wait now let's start going
through this and see what's in store
okay so this first new image that we got
here is a grandfather clock
i know exactly what this is you know how
i know what this is
i read the screenplay for it guys i
don't know what's going on his
grandfather o'clock
this clock is counting down everything
in hawkins i mean i did hear
david harbor i almost said david hopper
uh david that works david hopper i
wonder if he gets called that on set
probably um david harbor talked about
how this season would go with a little
bit more
into hopper's backstory which is
something i've been itching to find
specifically with his dad i think
entailing like the vietnam war
something about new york maybe this is
like in his home
he's got a little it could be there yeah
um
family heirloom of sorts that's more
sinister than it appears at first glance
one sec i'm just going to share this
comment on screen this is one of the top
comments here actually has i read the
first sentence here
from the trolling master which is a
suspicious name i have some interesting
info about the grandfather clock when
we're watching season one i noticed in
the flashback scene when 11 is in the
void trying to make contact with the
demogorgon if you listen
closely you can hear the sound of a
clock yes the
the ticking clock motif that that
elevates when 11
walks towards the demogorgon and the
sound gets faster and slightly louder as
levi gets closer to the endemic organ
then it stops once eleven touches the
demogorgon ooh
so what if she's like you know a part of
her trying to get back into the void or
something like that could be or maybe
it's got something to do with you know
maybe it's a tool they use in the
brainwashing and in the you know
interpolation of the upside down and
whatnot
yeah i thought like the that sound
effect was this more mainly used as a
motif because it's a commonly used motif
the sound of a ticking clock
if it has some type of physical
manifestation here some type of
entry gateway or or whatever that would
be pretty cool if it actually came to
fruition considering the
upside down is often an alternate time
type of dealio that you're dealing with
20 22 oh i totally missed that text went
by so fast all right so then we got
another shot here
she is not being take what is she
looking at you think
all right guys let's enhance her eyes
that's enhanced reflections
is that will i don't know what this
looks like the kind of thing where like
fbi cia agents take a character out to
like the middle of the desert it almost
looks like they're being like
apprehended on their way out of town or
something like that but yeah either way
it looks like these are like
goons come to scoop her up back up all
right i just had a crazy plot
a theory idea just based off of all
types of movie cliches they have the fbi
government people have discovered
something
discover like different entrances to the
upside down
and so they have found something out in
like the middle of the desert somewhere
and they
abduct 11. they need her to open it up
for them
and that's what she's looking at i
thought this was behind me but it's not
you don't know what you're messing yeah
because these people do not look russian
they look
very very very american but they could
be russian uh spies you know you never
know
and then here you got this beautiful
shot here i'm assuming that looks like
steve over here in the corner here yeah
that's gotta be jokiria that's gotta be
nancy based off the hairstyle well it
looks like there's someone behind her on
her
to her left and then so i mean is it
dustin and lucas
oh there's gotta be like the kids yeah
because there's multiple legs here yeah
so one of them's gotta be dustin just
because you would be fools not to
continue the steve dustin relationship
yeah
yeah okay that's that's definitely what
it is and then and the money shot of all
the kids
yeah looky there everyone's home we're
missing some kids though
we're missing a fin we don't have a wolf
hard there's no will either yeah no will
that's suspicious maybe they're backing
the upside down
who's this guy that's lucas that's lucas
it must be what lucas didn't die or
anything he looks so
much older so everyone looks kind of the
same yeah
he looks so much older that's right man
what the hell
i mean that's lucas but i'm pretty sure
oh my god he looks so different to me
has just been so long since i've seen
lucas he looks entirely he looks so
he's so much older but he's looking fly
in there he's got that new haircut too
he's got that flat top yeah yeah it
looks great
that's great and then here we go this
new shot of popper yeah so i feel like i
wonder if these are all kind of coming
from the same sequence the kids entering
in the grandfather clock i'm imagining
where he's going
is where the grandfather clock is it
looks like it's more official of a place
than like a house or something just
given what that fixture looks like
that's true yeah but part of me does
wonder like that could be a cool thing
is like if it is the same sequence and
they're just on two different sides of
reality from it or something like that
well he's like dredged in blood
and has bird marks blood or black goo
yeah okay so maybe this is probably
actually right it's probably still in
russia then he's messing people up
looking for answers i'm trying to escape
that looks great you got some
cheerleaders yeah we've still got a
little recognize any of these
cheerleaders
not recognize anybody speaking of upside
down there's a
that looks like steve looking at a car
that has set on fire
recognize that hair anywhere but he
wasn't in this car crash so this is kind
of an interesting take
because clearly he's coming from quite a
distance or maybe he was following
someone tracking them down and then bam
their car flipped over and did that
hollywood
instantly explode thing that does not
happen in real life
uh steve's a highway patrolman now
that's his same job steve in this
trailer then steve is under water
shirt wrapped around his flashlight here
it looks like he's at an aquarium here
that's kind of the vibe i'm getting it
could be
could be or in a lake or quarry or
something i don't know like maybe
there's a lake just off the highway and
maybe whoever was in the car like ran
off into the woods
and we'll play some more dungeons and
dresses
let's try all this new footage and this
looks like a fl i feel like we would
have seen like leaked photos of millie
bobby brown if she like shaved her head
again or something like that yeah maybe
she did maybe i mean i don't know
i wouldn't be surprised at all if they
pull like a oh [ __ ] moment out of her
coming back with her head shaved again
after making something out of her heavy
hair this season or whatever but at the
same time i feel like they just cut back
to old footage again it seems like we're
really going back to some more origin
details here
kids going down on their bicycles can't
do stranger things without that
all right well cool little sneak peek
cool little tease
2022 we still got a while away but you
best bet we're going to be covering that
when it comes out but guys what do you
think about this little teaser are you
upset that we haven't got an official
trailer we're a little earth
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least
valente i figured it out you must be
trapped at the upside down because
that's the only excuse as to why you
have been so
steadfast and supportive for so long and
yet
so invisible in the process i mean i
find myself thinking what if
j.n is stranded fighting for his life
tooth and nail becoming a hardened
warrior
in a sci-fi alternate dimension goring
demogorgons left and right making a
little hobble for yourself out of their
rotten carcasses just to keep
warm and have shelter at night i hope
you've not be following this fate but in
the same time you would be a pretty big
badass if you were to emerge from that
so maybe just
spend a little more time down there
and then you know keep keep keep that
pledge coming